testing the idiom straight as an arrow
so close means jumping through a whole
lot of Hoops and the weapon of choice is
a compound bow
we're almost there and now it's time to
dial in the aim on our compound bow and
in order to do that without destroying a
ton of arrows we've scooched everything
to the right we've placed this aiming
hole well exactly exactly 12 inches to
the right that we hope to do like 95% of
our dialing in without the danger of the
axis in the way so that when we're done
we scooch the whole rig back 12 inches
and fire it through all the Rings in
theory in practice quite honestly I have
no idea if we're going to be able to do
it if a test arrow can make it clean
through the yellow ring and go on to hit
the bull's eye they know that at least
they have a chance to match Odysseus
after one or two deft adjustments I'm
gonna give it one more little bump here
they're set to fire range is going hot
alright firing in three two one
come here look we're very respectively
closed
we touched we touched the ring it's not
good enough
they'll have to reload recalibrate and
try again to lining up this arrow has
proven to be a lot more difficult than
we were expecting because normally you
aim for the thing that's at the end of
the arrows flight like our target but
because we have something that's in the
middle of its flight which is our ring
that we're trying to get it through it's
proving to be a lot more difficult to
line it up but each successive shot gets
them closer and closer until firing
three absolutely perfect and just as
important did the arrow sail through the
ring that's in our zone yeah Nick it's
time perfect alright let's move the
whole rig over yeah okay so it's with
extreme care that they're finely
calibrated shooting rig is moved back in
line with that
ominous array of steel rings and don't
forget the only character to ever make
this shot was fictitious itsgotime our
axes are lined up our bow shooting rate
has been aimed to the best of our
abilities adjacent to the axis and now
it's been moved in two lines so it's
looking down the throat of history
Odysseus here we come
it's worth recalling that this challenge
in itself is a myth there's no record of
anyone before beau master Byron
attempting it and no expectation that
it's actually possible range is going
hot
here we go Oh dis just shut firing in
three two
[Music]
one it's a one-shot wonder actually it's
more like a miracle I did not expect
that the first time that should not have
worked like that I need to check that
high-speed I need to see what happens
I don't I don't believe my eyes
this is literally a mythological shot
alright guys it's time to call this one
does an arrow actually fly straight well
Odysseus used a longbow and we were only
able to accomplish this with a compound
bow this is true and I'm pretty sure
Odysseus wasn't a robot I have to agree
with you on that one every error that we
did shoot had oscillation and wiggle to
it but we did just shoot the straightest
shot that we could ever shoot that's
true
and even if we use modern technology in
this we still were able to accomplish
this feat all right I think that makes
it obviously plausible plausible Oh see
see it's listen to robot no why would he
be a robot
[Music]